yippie kai movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm revealing the top 50
devilish details you missed in lucifer's
final season from ingenious easter eggs
and call backs to hilarious meta
references and hidden jokes spoilers are
ahead of course so take care
since she first stole the hearts of lucy
fans in the pilot my name's beatrice but
everybody calls me trixie that's a
hooker's name what's the hooker ask your
mother scarlett estevez has gifted us
some wonderful scenes and there's some
fun easter eggs at mazes wedding to
memorable moments between her and trixie
so when maez walks down the aisle as she
reaches her little friend they do a fist
bump then their signature cutthroat sign
which we saw a longer version of in the
third season episode mr and mrs mazakin
smith
later at the reception as adam and dr
linda walk into the scene watch the
background very carefully as while eve
is enjoying a glass of something sparkly
maize is pouring something a little
stronger after which she checks around
and surreptitiously tries to pass the
glass of hard liquor to trixie until
that is eve realizes what her new wife's
up to and stops her but this isn't the
first time that mays has offered trixie
an alcoholic drink as she also did that
as a bartender at lux in season one is
this australian temple sure
check out the pile of presents at the
reception and among the boxes you'll
spot a spiky gift with a festive white
bow attached as one of hell's foremost
torturers mazakin certainly knows her
weaponry and will doubtless appreciate
this addition to her collection
especially as this particular weapon is
called a morning star
of course it's at the wedding that ella
reveals she knows her friend's celestial
secret and for lucy fans the apocalypse
board she created to work it all out is
the gift that just keeps giving for
example there's her theories about what
caused down the frog to fall from the
sky which include whether it's some kind
of weird side effect from detective
dan's favorite dessert the red-eyes
post-it note on lucy's photo is a nod to
his devil eyes which he used very
briefly in season three on ella's
brother who could well have told her at
some point likely leading her to this
clue and proving what a great detective
mind she has we can see she figured out
everyone's secret including charlie
being half angel amaze a demon that
picture of maize by the way is from the
hilarious time in season five she
dressed up and tried to imitate ella to
make herself more emotionally available
oh my god i have that exact same shirt
yes you did wait did you steal my
clothes as for dan it seems ella briefly
entertained ideas that he was also a
supernatural creature like a werewolf
vampire or centaur but ended up
dismissing them funny for many reasons
including the actor kevin alejandro
actually starred in the vampire tv show
true blood and also goddess who dan
dated has centaurs in her new universe
the feather in the bag is a reference to
the season 5 finale where the writers
had some fun with us making it seem ella
was about to discover the truth i think
i know what this is about lucifer you
you do come on so tell me the truth you
hit an emu with your car didn't you by
the way fun fact when season five was
going to be the final season the plan
was for ella to discover the truth right
at the very end in the closing montage
where she was babysitting charlie and he
sprouted wings oh and i love that along
with the many wild headlines and
apocalyptic post-it notes ella's also
written what looks like a rather more
mundane reminder to herself did you turn
off the stove
lucifer's to-do list is an eclectic mix
and funny insight into his mind he's
already decided against becoming god and
manages to bond with his daughter rory
and up there next is checking in on
father frank from the season 1 fan
favorite episode a priest walks into a
bar it makes sense that lucy would want
to visit him in heaven and see what he's
up to given how hard he took his death
father frank was one of the few people
to realise that lucifer was actually the
devil and he reminded him that god had
not abandoned him you're wrong lucifer
remember
your father has a plan it's also hard
not to chuckle at lucy's idea to mess
with dan by naming him after casper the
friendly ghost as well as his plan to
re-watch all 12 seasons of bones that's
246 episodes thank you very much that
show was the perfect combination of
procedure and banter as for sao paulo's
inclusion on the list that might be a
reference to the real-life serial killer
imprisoned in the brazilian city who
calls himself lucifer and has apparently
killed many other prison inmates he
views as bad people perhaps lucy intends
to put a stop to someone using his name
for their own ends as he did with
lucifoni the lucifer impersonator from
season one i'm lucifer freaking morning
star oh
are you now we can't have you running
around cheating the loose of a brand now
can we because as we know one thing
lucifer hates in particular is being
used as a scapegoat for the bad and evil
choices human beings make by themselves
well the devil made me do it i have
never made any one of them do anything
and of course because this is lucifer's
list as a final reference to a new
sexual position he wants to try out a
billboard for the tv series diablo based
on lucifer's original season 1 poster
pops up in the episode buckets of
baggage and that ad first appeared
during a magnificently meta season 5
murder investigation you want to find
the killer figure out their urination
isn't there a better word for that and
interestingly enough the deliberate
choice to insert the diablo billboard
into this particular aerial shot of
sunset boulevard means it's juxtaposed
with a real-life catholic billboard that
plays on both the u.s got milk campaign
and the biblical miracle of water being
turned into wine and also in this shot
is a real-life strip club who's named
seventh vale is a nod to the dance of
the seven veils performed by salome to
get king herod to execute john the
baptist when lucifer ponders what to
wear to visit jimmy barnes i wish you'd
prefer the iconic white or
pomegranate for more of an original sin
vibe he seems to confirm the theory of
some scholars that pomegranates not
apples were the fruit that tempted adam
and eve in the garden of eden the
red-seeded fruit has been a running
theme in the show appearing prominently
in paintings at charlotte the goddess's
law office and getting a shout out as
one of original god's mysterious
creations it does inexplicable things
from time to time marsupials
pomegranates the gallbladder and during
lucifer's investigation of jimmy's hell
loop they take a period tour back to the
80s where playing at the movie theater
is althea queen of the quarks one of
penelope decker's best-known movies
posters for the film have appeared
previously on the show and it was also
mentioned in season five miss decker i'm
a huge fan atheia queen of the quarks
that should have won you an oscar while
chloe's mum doesn't appear in the final
season lucy mentions that trixie's
staying with her in the opening episode
grandma penelope's heart's grown three
times the size thanks to her time with
trixie that's a reference to the grinch
whose heart triples in size after he
learns the true meaning of christmas in
particular thanks to a little girl
called cindy lou who and it's also a nod
to scarlet estevez who plays trixie and
her role in illumination's animated
grinch movie as one of cindy lou's
friends there are several hat tips this
season to the 1990s romantic thriller
ghost from maze's reaction to ghost dan
asking her to give ella a message no i
did not trip silver you're on my wedding
night to be your whoopi goldberg to lucy
and chloe's unchained melody moment in
the panic room and there's even a cameo
from patrick swayze's brother don who
pops up as a gas station owner during
lucy's search for his daughter hat tip
to raghu for pointing that out on my
last video
when the morningstar family ends up on
dr linda's couch with a case of future
child angst the symmetry of lucifer and
rory's body language not only reflects
how much they have in common she takes
after you and her exits but it also
mirrors the season 5 scene where lucy
and god had their own therapy session
with the good doctor speaking of
similarities both rory and god also seem
less than impressed with lucy's large
alcohol collection nothing is ever good
enough for you where's your kitchen just
a wall of scotch an entire wall of
liquor upstairs and it's all just
whiskey and both lucy and rory's devil
faces pop up when their respective
fathers are under threat plus they also
have very similar tastes in tv the best
tv show you have ever seen
bones the spin-off from my time kicks
your bones his ass more bones is the
perfect combination of procedure and
banter so in many ways the apple really
hasn't fallen far from the tree
lucy's love affair with bones actually
began back in season three watched all
12 seasons it's riveting stuff it's like
watching a documentary of us and in
season six he's still not over at
getting the chop at fox the same channel
that also canceled lucifer this is a
terrible idea worst i've heard since
some genius decided to cancel bones in
fact in episode five lucy thinks he
disappears from rory's life due to death
by dentist as dr kyle seems strangely
familiar to him but then he realizes why
do these commercials ever run during
bones syndicated audiences are tooth
decay audiences which reminds me of
another time that lucy's bone's
obsession led him astray in season three
detective i've seen that man before
who's the killer that man turned out to
be an actor from bones in both real life
and in lucifer and on top of all those
tributes to the former fox show bones
actress patricia belcher also guest
stars in season six as loretta i love
the song choice of worship by the
artists laces for eve amaze's wedding
and the way that episode's editor has
cut the action to the song's lyrics is
just fantastic as it gives us moments
like the camera focusing on lucifer and
chloe as the words maybe in another life
ring out foreshadowing their separation
by the end of the show and their
eventual reunion in hell then there's a
shot of maze with the lyrics because
heaven won't take me then we cut to eve
on the line devil won't take me which
certainly fits her season 4 experience
with lucifer then we move to lucy and
chloe again as laces sings nothing feels
better than you before cutting to ghost
stand followed by a menadiel on the line
if angels won't save me given eve's
garden of eden origins it feels
especially appropriate that she and mays
are married in front of a large tree and
a pair of flower-covered rings in their
own little paradise of sorts the
real-life location for the wedding is
the lush garden of the walt disney
concert hall in la which seems extra
fitting as imbala v plays the original
cine eve with all the excitement and
innocent wonder of a disney princess
with an added naughty side the garden
theme continues at the reception with
maize and eve sitting in front of a
heart-shaped tree covered in pinky red
fairy lights a colour associated with
both love and the devil and it also
reminds me of classic images of the tree
of knowledge
another delightful little detail you
could even say it's the icing on the
cake it's the cake topper which is
actually a mini version of either maize
dressed in the very same outfits they
got married in
maize's choice of gifts for kids has
certainly stayed consistent over the
seasons with newborn rory getting a
cutting-edge present from the demon just
as baby charlie and trixie did in season
four as you know she's not allowed to
play with mice relax dan these knives
aren't for trixie for a baby and talking
of charlie at his birthday party there's
a big present wrapped up in serpent
covered paper a hint perhaps that it's
from his uncle lucifer and charlie
getting his wings on his second birthday
fits nicely with the fact that he's
entering the terrible twos the period of
development when toddlers often
experience temper tantrums as they test
their boundaries and want greater
independence while a menadil is pleased
as punch linda looked shocked as after
all he told her in season five their son
wouldn't be getting wings at all do you
not realize that this is good news no
more ugly ass bubble wrap no more
worrying about a head-on with the 737
and at the polar opposite end of the
gift-giving spectrum to maze is ella and
what else would you expect as a present
for miss lopez and something you could
give a nice big old hug to like a teddy
bear there is of course a lot more to
discuss about that ending and whether it
was a good way to finish the series
which i go into in full detail in my
ending explained video tap here to watch
that or follow the link in the video
description so what were your favorite
moments in the final season and what
other details or easter eggs did you
spot let me know in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this then a thumbs up
and a share are hugely appreciated tap
left to check out my next loose of a
video or tap right for something else
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time yippee kai movie
lovers
you